salut c'est Hugo cette semaine dans la
grande histoire je vous partage la suite
de notre série documentaire consacrée au
skinhead dans ce deè épisode vous allez
découvrir les nazi skin ces skinet
d'extrême droite qui ont pris le pouvoir
sur la mouvance au début des années 80 à
cette époque leur ultraviolence se
déchaîne contre d'autres bandes et
contre des immigrés croisés au hasard
dans les rues de Paris pour comprendre
comment ce mouvement a basculé on a fait
le choix d'aller aussi interroger les
plus extrêmes d'entre eux pour vous
montrer qui ils sont réellement
une horde de skinhead armée de barre de
fer de manche de pioche et de Bad de
baseball tous ces militants extrémistes
il sont connus pour des actions de
violence tant sur la violence urbaine
que sur des violences d'ordre
raciste je suis africain africaini alors
qui c'estcell
nonc
[Musique]
je m'appelle William delini et avant
j'étais connu comme petit Willy un
ancien skinette quoi violent et connu
sur Paris
[Musique]
quoi j'ai vécu à Bagnolet une ambiance
de
cité qui est extrêmement difficile pour
évoluer
[Musique]
psychologiquement j'avais un père qui
était alcoolique une mère qui pleurait
beaucoup et puis dans ces cités bah il y
a beaucoup de gens qui boivent aussi
vous entendez des cris il y a des bruits
partout j'avais eu quand même un ami à
13 ans qui était mort d' verdose un
autre qui
s'était suicidé du 9e
étage donc on est confronté à une
violence qui nous dépasse qu'on est
enfant on se retrouve dans une situation
où on est finalement perdu et on cherche
une
identité j'étais comme un légionnaire
j'étais focalisé je veux rentrer dans un
gang je veux être un skin j'étais
vraiment comme une religion quelque
chose de vraiment je m'étais préparé
tout et j'ai commencé à prendre le
démarche à toujours faire la tête à
regarder les gens des ququ me Mata ça
partait j'avais un surnom à cette époque
aussi on m'app coup de boule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'enfer je pouvais casser des vitrines
en faet de barre à coup de tête donc
quand je mettais un coup de tête ça ça
vraiment un
[Musique]
impact
à cette époque là il y avait un groupe
qui s'appelait screw driver en
Angleterre qui était tout habillé en
noir avec des symboles fasciste et
cetera et c'est quelque chose qui nous
attiré beaucoup beaucoup de gens
trouvent la politique barbante et
certains aspects le sont
effectivement mais aller un concert et
écouter un groupe avec lequel vous êtes
d'accord c'est beaucoup plus amusant que
d'aller à une réunion politique et nous
pouvons atteindre ainsi beaucoup plus de
gens leur musique il l'appelle la O ce
sont les Anglais qui l'ont pratiqué en
premier mais depuis près de 3 ans Paris
à son groupe il répète dans un studio de
banlieu on avait un groupe de musique
[Musique]
evolskin c'est un groupe mondialement
connu chez les skin en fait mondialement
[Musique]
connu
nous et le P de C campus on est content
nous sommes bê et méchant comme on
traite souvent les skins de bêtes et
méchant nous on dit oui on est bête et
méchant et en plus on est content quoi
voilà evelskin va va marquer parce que
ça êre le premier groupe
[Musique]
politique c'est le groupe de musique de
de cich c'est ce que on avait défini en
interne jeis voà pour pour se diffuser
il faut aussi qu'on ait un moyen de de
communication et la musique est un moyen
de communication ce
[Musique]
j t
àavers
les
c'est des paroles vraiment dures quoi
sur un racisme où c'est comme la
rigolate tu vois c'est c'est
rigoler avec des choses qui sont qu'on
peut pas se moquer quoi tu vois comme
des camps de concentration des choses
comme ça c'était vraiment violent tu
vois tu vois vraiment
[Musique]
violent le premier concert qu'on a fait
on avait été en banieu par en bieu
parisienne gens on rentr on pay pas on a
viré le groupe sur scène on a pris le
place on a fait le
concert et après on s'est tapévec
presque toute la
salle cétait ça l'ambiance à l'épo
cétait une ambiance vraiment pas
seulement un groupe de musique c'est des
gens qui ont une crédibilité urbaine on
va dire
avec des membres qui sont connus dans la
rue avec des gens comme petit Willy qui
est reconnu comme un gros
bagarur avec des gens comme
snif qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vous
croisez une bande de dans Laue ça fait
boom à l'époque il y avait une boutique
qui s'appelait en fait le New
Rose le seul magasin de disque punk not
type de musique donc il fallait qu'on y
soit on s'est implanté ici avec de
nouvelles personnes qui étaient vraiment
plus
il a des G qui ont rej une bande
vraiment de
fou va faire peur quand
Mme va rassembler des gens qui sont
quand même là pour pour la
bagarre
AG
amainlais rou àol sur des Rangers
renforc avec des coquilles
d'acier
il faut savoir quand je vous parle que
je me battais tous les jours contre des
modes des skin des red skin des Pun des
antifas et C sont des gens qui avaient
un
uniforme qui Savit ce qu'il faisait
quand tu en uniforme tu es en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
guerre je dire chose c'est que le
problème des skin maintenant norm il se
disent skin donc c'est pour taper sur la
gueule des Arabes et en fait il tape sur
la gueule de tout le monde tout ce qui a
un autre look tout ce qui est différent
tu
lamines je me rappelle une fois j'ai
défoncé un gars tu sais parce qu'il
m'avait juste regardé une fois juste il
s'était retourné je l'avais frappé
tellement fort que il y avait le
trottoir et il y avait la roue d'une
voiture et j'essayais de rentrer sa tête
comme ça à de pied un truc de fou quoi
toi et le gars je l'ai laissé
inconscient j'ai été joué à 5 m à côté
au flippeur tu vois et les flips sont
ven serré tout
vois quand tu frappes sur des gens de
cette manière là avec tellement de haine
tu sais pas ce qui se passe tu laisses
les gens dans le canivau tu laisses les
gens inconscients je me suis fait
ramasser le matin par exemple chez mes
parents pour des histoires de meurtre
aussi hein parce que il y a a des gens
qui laissaient leur vie moi on est venu
me chercher pour ça voilà je peux pas en
dire
plus dans cette logique de trôner au
sommet de l'écosystème subculturel le
skin se voit comme le le roi de la la
jungle en fait des de toutes les tribus
souvent c'était très simple j'avançais
dans la rue j'en croisais un je tartais
je continuais je m'arrêtais même pas
[Musique]
les premières bandes françaises en fait
vont vraiment être associés à des des
quartiers c'est d'abord le lieu qui va
définir les bandes les skins c'est une
menace à partir du moment où tu es à
Chatel leséal les skin c'est une menace
citée à Saint-Michel on parle la bande
de Bonsergent la bande de tolbiaac les
skins c'est une menace si tu prends la
ligne 9 les skins c'est une menace si tu
prends la ligne 10
toutes ces bandes V être plus ou moins
en concurrence entre elles au niveau de
la réputation savoir quelle est la bande
la plus
[Musique]
furieuse quand je rencontre un are
skin soit on le fracassait on le
dépouillait les chaussures il repartait
en slip soit il assurait on prenait dans
la bande mais il y a pas de demimesure à
cette
[Musique]
époque
on voulait pas de
nous oui on est
d'arrivé SK en 80 n on é en
82 cétait trop tard
pour sont
fait est-ce que vous avez fréquenté
Serge aou l'époque non il est venu
qu'une seule fois ici il est jamais
revenu peut-êtreit
mieux ici à SaintMichel il traî toute la
nuit cherchant la BAGAR
après le guitariste africain il sen
Prenn un skin rival à l'entrée d'une
brasserie La Cure été vraiment 83
84 là chacun chacun décidé de prendre de
choisir son
camp
un moment tous les gars des h sont
arrivés ils sont arrivés à une 30
quarantaine quand même tu vois on essayé
nous nous dégoûter de la chose Manu
military mais ça n'a pas
marché et là il y en a un qui vient me
voir qui avait tatoué sur la la tête
comme ça fait en France avec une croix
un skinet des h comme ça et là je suis
dis bon c'est
partir je explosé la tête comme ça un
coup de tête et là ce qui s'est passé
c'est que en fait les 40 gars qui avait
tu vois ils ont été quel part
impressionné qu'un petit gamin de 15 ans
puisse mettre une tête à un meneur
quelque part vois les bagares de rue
c'est très rapide c'est pas comme dans
les films c'est pas il y a pas 26 coups
comme ça ça très vite un coup vous
sèchez vous tombez c'est le premier qui
tire j'ai pris trois coups de Coutau
coincé sur un capot de
voiture voilà et heureusement la lame
était pas très grande le cœur a pas été
touché à 5 cm c'est passé un soir de
Noël un beau cadeau de
[Musique]
Noël cette violence c'est quelque chose
qui va rester quelque part dans l'ADN du
mouvement skin en fait il va commence à
avoir des gros titres sur la violence
des skin et notamment la violence qui
vont produire dans les stades de
football la musique o
associe la musique et le foot et le foot
en l'occurrence le higanisme la violence
dans le foot le groupe O qui à l'époque
incarne le plus cette dimension là c'est
un groupe qui s'appelle cocknerject qui
revendiquent leur passion de la violence
dans les stades ils ont même une chanson
qui s'appelle war on the terraist donc
la guerre dans les
[Musique]
tribunes sport ce soir au Parc des
Princes franceangleterre de football
c'est un peu un événement parce que
c'est la première fois depuis 21 ans que
l'équipe nationale d'Angleterre vient au
Parc des Princes une équipe d'Angleterre
qui de toute façon ne nous a jamais
réussi c'est ce que je vous propose de
voir dans le sujet les stades de
football c'estes temples de la classe
ouvrière vont devenir important pour les
skin parce que ça une manière aussi de
de se voir en nombre là quand ils
arrivent pour soutenir leur équipe ils
peuvent être des centaines et donc ils
ont vraiment là ils voient leur
mouvement vivre il était pas question
que les Anglais débarquent et se croit
chez eux non plus il y a eu un un accord
cassite entre les différentes bandes
parisiennes pour ce jour-là on est tout
le monde uni contre
[Musique]
VA
plusieurs milliers d'anglais font le
déplacement à Paris à l'époque c'est une
tradition pour les les Anglais de se
déplacer en nombre à l'étranger puisque
c'est une manière de montrer qu'ils
existent plus que jamais sur cette scène
et qu'il la domine c'est une histoire de
réputation le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
higanisme on est en France on est chez
nous les Anglais viennent on va leur
montrer qu'on peut défendre notre
territoire et donc exister sur la scène
du
holiganisme
[Musique]
alors cela peut paraître stupide du
point de vue extérieur mais c'est la
logique de ces gens-là à l'époque on est
clan contre clan gang contre gang
violence contre violence et on existe en
tant que houigan
[Applaudissements]
Français on s'était donné rendez-vous au
porte de saint-clou sauf que quand on
est arrivé les Anglais étaient déjà là
depuis le matin ou midi donc chacun
chaque bande AA parqu avec les Anglais
dans le métro un peu partout donc on
s'est jamais vraiment retrouvé comme
c'était
prévu on boit quelques verr avant et on
prend le métro pour aller au Parc des
Princes on avait un wagon de skinette tu
vois et d'un seul coup on voit les
oliganes sur lequ il nous voit arriver
en en métro et ils font Mo French
skineds on
fonce on se tapait à coup de Coutau à
coup truc de fou quoi je me souviens il
y avait un anglais frappu et oh le trapu
il faut pas que je le rate évidemment je
mets une patate un coup de point et je
le rate forcément là j'ai un copain qui
arrive Bou il lui met un coup de genou
en sautant et lui tape la tête contre le
métro qui arrivé donc ça l'a calmé truc
de fou ça a été vraiment une guerre
France Angleterre on a sauté sur le qu
on a couru sur tout le tunnel jusqu la
station suivante les Anglais nous ont
pas suivi on sen est sorti
[Musique]
là je souvienss bien épque les premiers
incidents éclatent autour du Parc des
Princes entre Anglais et Français et on
sent d'emblé que ça va partir en
vrille j'avais taillé des des barres de
fer de 50 60 cm le but c'était avant de
tomber on en fait tomber le
maximum j'ai vu l'objet à la télévision
le
lendemain voilà j'ais ont cassé
oui mais les Anglais ils ont la pratique
et le métier ils sont rendus compte
qu'on était que 5 mais il devait être
100 150 bah j'en ai pris un j'en ai pris
deux et puis j'ai jeté mon objet
contendant et je suis allé me réfugier
au terminus qui était un café parce que
dehors il y avait une heure de sauvage
qui m'aurait fait la peau s'il m'avait
mis la main dessus à titre personnel je
n'ai jamais connu un tel chaos autour du
Parc des Princes avant un match ça c'est
une
certitude une dizaine de supporters
seront interpellés deux autres seront
hospitalisé l'un a été atteint d'un
coupau l'autre d'un coup de
ha le français qui a pris un coup de
Hachette c'est des
prouvir ma prouv mè qui é en train de se
dire oh la pauvre maman pauvre maman oh
la pauvre maman qui av son fils bah
c'était le
sien on est en haut de la tribune je
sais pas si vous connaissez le Parc des
Princes il une tribune en haut une
tribune en bas à Boulogne nous on était
en haut les Anglais étaient en bas et
les Anglais nous provoquaient ouais ou
venir et on leur jetait bien sûr des
chaises qu'on pétait on pétait les les
sièges jetait dans la
gueule il y a un anglais qui était face
à nous qui fait en anglais come on comme
ça c'est con parce que je n'aime même
pas le
foot je suis pas n pas de football donc
je risque de me faire buter pour un truc
dont j'ai rien à
[__] j'espère que ce deuxième épisode
vous a intéressé un grand merci à
Aurélie Simon et Nicola Dumont avec qui
j'ai eu la chance de réaliser cette
série documentaire un grand merci
également à mathas et Jean-Christophe
Marco ainsi qu'à toutes les équipes de
brut qui ont participé à sa fabrication
n'hésitez pas à poser un like et à vous
abonner à la chaîne pour ne rien rater
de nos prochaines vidéos et moi je vous
donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour le dernier épisode de notre série
skinad